bonsoir béchade merci d'être avec nous
un rebond donc de 42 pensant satellite
pour les résultats de 2020 à déplomber
pourtant par la crise sanitaire
évidemment comment on s'explique cela
c'est la question tout le monde se pose
on a un rebond de 42% après une chute de
- 45
donc je veux dire qu'on n'est pas encore
revenu au niveau de 10 dans de
distribuer fin 2019 début 2020 ou les
hypothèses à l'époque c'était plutôt
autour de 2 70 75 milliards de
dividendes
on s'entendait donc
total allait distribuer généreusement 7
milliards je dirais que c'est un
dividende inchangé pour l'instant pour
l'année 2000 21
alors je dis pas qui aura pas peut-être
un petit quelque chose
un reliquat en décembre enfin pour
l'instant on n'annonce pas chez total
par exemple de forte hausse du dividende
pour les banques
il ya eu donc une année une année sans
on va avoir une reprise du versement des
dividendes sur des niveaux de
profitabilité qui pour l'instant n'ont
pas retrouvé non plus les niveaux de fin
des bulles 2020 alors est-ce que c'est
choquant que les entreprises versent des
dividendes à mon sens non parce que
c'est le jeu du capitalisme
après évidemment si l'entreprise se sert
de l'argent avancé par l'état pour
récompenser les actionnaires là
effectivement on pouvait on peut ouvrir
de grands yeux
pour l'instant j'ai acquis a pas encore
de cas vraiment choquant je sais par
exemple que danone a exercé un le pge
qui sera ensuite remboursés j'irais pas
jusqu'a les accusés de se servir de ces
sommes pour verser un dividende aux
actionnaires d'ailleurs on a beaucoup à
reprocher d'ailleurs à danone de ne pas
être assez généreux et ce qui a coûté
récemment sa tête à son à son président
ça n'explique pas comment est possible
ce rebond de 42% alors qu'on nous dit
qu'il ya une crise sanitaire majeure
comment cela se fait-il que les
résultats aient autant bon vit cette
année sa jambe ou alors les résultats
les plus spectaculaires
on les a observés dans le secteur du
luxe
le luxe est absolument inoxydable on le
voit bien que le monde soit en crise ou
pas le luxe progresse toujours
il ya eu un tout petit passage à vide
l'année dernière premiers débuts
deuxième trimestre parce que les chinois
étaient étaient moins présents
et puis les géants du luxe ont très bien
rebondi en recourant massivement
aux ventes en ligne s'il s'était
contenté effectivement d'attendre que
les touristes chinois reviennent dans
les aéroports sur les champs elysées
oxford street où la 5e avenue
il ferait grise mine donc les ventes ont
très très fortement progressé aussi bien
pour lvmh et toutes ces marques que pour
kering c'est-à-dire gucci
on a vu le même phénomène d'ailleurs
même pour pour tiffany qui appartient
maintenant également à lvmh en fait tous
les groupes du luxe ont magnifiquement
performé durant toute l'année 2020 je ne
sais pas si les asiatiques pour conjurer
cette période pénible ont renforcé leurs
achats d'articles de luxe en tout cas
dans les chiffres d'affaires c'est assez
spectaculaire joie par exemple que pour
lvmh dans le secteur de la maroquinerie
joaillerie et l'horlogerie
ils font plus 50 + 50 % et des profits
absolument record donc n'oublions pas
que les entreprises du cac 40 sont
d'abord des multinationales et que la
france est typiquement dans l'excès dans
l'exemple du secteur du luxe
la france ne représente que 15 ou 20 %
de leur chiffre d'affaires
et je dirais que au niveau marge les
meilleures marges elles sont fait
effectivement avec la clientèle
asiatique
si on reparle des banques quelques
secondes l'année 2020 n'a pas été
catastrophique puisqu'il ya en fait il
ya eu très très peu de faillite ce qui
les aurait peut-être obligé à augmenter
leurs provisions pour pertes
on voit que ça n'a pas été le cas grâce
aux aides aux états unis il ya eu
beaucoup moins dead et pourtant on voit
également que les les banques
retire par centaines de millions voire
par milliards leurs provisions donc ça
augmente mécaniquement le résultat alors
résultat distribuable ou pas en tout cas
les banques pour l'instant se porte bien
la plupart des secteurs se portent très
bien et la seule déception finalement au
sein du cac 40 c'est atos c'est à peu
près là le seul exemple d'une entreprise
ou vraiment ça va moins bien aujourd'hui
que ça n'allait fin 2020 ou au printemps
2020 donc ça se passe bien pardonnez-moi
pardonnez moi on nous promet une crise
économique majeure à l'issue de cette
crise sanitaire ça veut dire que ces
chiffres là sont quand même plutôt
encourageant ou au finalement ça
concerne qu'une partie des des
entreprises ça ne veut pas dire grand
chose
il faut vraiment faire la différence
entre une multinationale
donc c'est à dire toutes les valeurs du
cac 40 la plupart des valeurs du sbf 120
dont les marchés se font majoritairement
à l'étranger et cette année on anticipe
une reprise de six et demi pour cent à
l'échelle planétaire
donc il faut vraiment clairement
distingués des entreprises qui font du
chiffre d'affaires en asie aux états
unis et des entreprises franco
françaises qui ont une zone de
chalandise local régional voire
peut-être nationale lorsque les aides
les pg e vont tous ces aides vont être
progressivement levées les problèmes
vont apparaître là jusqu'à présent les
entreprises peuvent repousser jusque
maintenant à avril 2022
le remboursement des prêts et c'est
simplement repoussé mais quel sera le
chiffre d'affaires de pme pmi françaises
même d'ici l'automne si la saison
estivale par exemple les ratés dans
l'hôtellerie la restauration
donc je fais vraiment clair la
différence entre des entreprises qui ont
une exposition au marché domestique et
des entreprises qui ont une exposition
internationale qui vit qui versent des
dividendes à des actionnaires des fonds
de retraite internationaux et en france
vous voyez la plupart des banquiers qui
aujourd'hui constate qu on a 150
milliards 180 milliards d' épargne les
gens qu on l épargne vous entendez tous
les conseillers bancaires assureurs vie
vous dire fait des actions allaient vers
la bourse il ya des dividendes et vous
avez des tas de fonds de retraite pour
qui
leur survie dépend aussi du fait que les
entreprises versent des dividendes donc
il ya à mon avis rien de choquant
par contre je voulais rajouter quelque
chose on fait beaucoup beaucoup
actuellement de débat autour ses
dividendes
mais quelque chose de discret et qui
rapporte autant aux actionnaires je vous
assure je là je suis très très sérieux
ce sont les rachats de titres
certes les entreprises dans une période
de crise on pourrait se dire ils doivent
être un petit peu à court de cash où ils
doivent peut-être attendre les plans de
relance pour participer à l'effort de
transition énergétique verdissement de
la planète est en fait vous apercevez
qu'il ya des beaucoup d'entreprises qui
ont des excès de cash et qui en profite
pour racheter leurs propres titres
et là je ne vous parle pas d'un
phénomène marginal puisque en france on
parle du versement de 50 2 milliards de
dividendes mais aux états unis pour 2021
n'anticipe plus de 500 ou 510 milliards
de dividendes versés et bien figurez
vous que les plans de rachats de titres
c'est à dire de la valeur restituer aux
actionnaires on attend entre 530 et 550
milliards donc qu'ils vont être versés
aux actionnaires se sont pas des
dividendes mais ça va quand même tombés
dans leurs poches et ça se compare à 838
150 milliards il y a deux ans c'est à
dire juste avant la crise
donc les dividendes c'est une chose mais
n'oublions pas également cette pratique
des rachats de titres et qui contribue
également à restituer beaucoup de valeur
aux actionnaires
apple par exemple a annoncé 90 milliards
de rachats de titres apple a réalisé un
bénéfice de 23 milliards
ils vendent ils vont distribuer une
partie mais c'est rien à côté des 90
milliards de rachats de titres c'est
surtout ça qui va profiter par exemple
aux actionnaires américains
en france les bars achats de titres ça
reste quelque chose encore assez
marginal actuellement qu'est ce qu'on a
comme plan a annoncé on arcelormittal ou
carrefours autour de 500 millions
donc vous voyez l'échelle est pas tout à
fait la même messi
l'économie redémarre vous verrez
également que les rachats de titres vont
un moment venir talonner les dividendes
en termes de richesse restituer aux
actionnaires merci nous avoir apporté
cet éclairage philippe béchade merci
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france